vamos a comenzar por ejemplo tomando be
que sea un sub espacio un sub espacio de
nuestro espacio de rn ok entonces
tenemos un sub espacio de rn y vamos a
suponer que conocemos su base es decir
tenemos el conjunto de vectores b1 b2
etcétera todos estos digamos que tenemos
acá vectores y este conjunto de los ves
es una base de nuestro sub espacio b ok
entonces tenemos una base de v que
significa que sea una base recordemos
esto significa que todos estos vectores
generan a los elementos de nuestro sub
espacio y además que son linealmente
independientes eso quiere decir que es
un conjunto minimal que genera a este su
espacio es decir no puede haber un
conjunto con menos elementos que genere
a nuestro sub espacio b entonces esto
inmediatamente nos dice por definición
que la dimensión que la dimensión de
nuestro sub espacio
al número de elementos que hay en la
base que son acá exactamente acá
entonces lo que vamos a tratar de hacer
en este vídeo es calcular cuál es la
dimensión o cómo se relaciona la
dimensión del complemento ortogonal de
nuestro sub espacio b y para hacerlo voy
a comenzar tomándome una matriz digamos
una matriz
ok esta matriz va a tener a los vectores
de la base como columnas es decir aquí
vamos a tener a b1 y esta es una columna
vamos a tener aquí a b 2 que también es
una columna y así sucesivamente hasta
beca ok que lo importante es que son
vectores que generan a nuestro espacio a
nuestro psuv espacio b ok entonces ve
nosotros lo podemos ver a nuestro psuv
espacio b lo podemos ver como el espacio
generado por los vectores b1 b2 hasta
beca aunque entonces este es el espacio
vectorial generado por el b1 b2 y así
sucesivamente hasta nuestro vector de
acá muy bien ahora esto definitivamente
por definición sabemos que es el espacio
columna de nuestra matriz a esto es el
espacio columna de la matriz a muy bien
y de hecho vimos en algún en el vídeo
anterior me parece
que el complemento ortogonal de nuestro
espacio columna era exactamente igual
que el espacio nulo de la matriz
transpuesta o que es el espacio nulo
izquierdo de la matriz a pero bueno
vamos a mencionarlo como el espacio nulo
de la matriz a transpuesta y esto
definitivamente es sí sí sí tenemos que
ver es el espacio columna de nuestra
matriz a entonces esto va a ser el
complemento ortogonal debe muy bien
entonces ya con esto dicho podemos
empezar a ver que sí que sí queremos
calcular la dimensión del ortogonal del
complemento ortogonal de b esto va a ser
lo mismo que calcular la dimensión del
espacio nulo de nuestra matriz a
transpuesta pero eso ya sabemos lo vimos
en algún vídeo que esto no es otra cosa
más que la nulidad
la nulidad de transpuesta de a
transpuesta verdad la dimensión del
espacio nulo o del núcleo depende de ahí
hay gente que le llama mejor núcleo hay
gente que le dice espacio nulo pero la
dimensión del espacio nulo de una matriz
a eso es a lo que se le conoce como
nulidad verdad y para ir calculando todo
esto voy a seguir construyendo otra
matriz de hecho voy a ver qué pasa con
la trans presta es decir si tengo a
transpuesta bueno notemos antes que la
matriz a tenía k columnas verdad cada
columnas y de cuantos cuanto cuántos
renglones tiene pues como cada vector se
encuentra en rn tendrá n n en el renglón
es verdad por supuesto que la matriz
transpuesta pues será de k por n y lo
que vamos a hacer es que cada uno de los
vectores en vez de ser columnas van a
ser renglones verdad y entonces nuestra
matriz a transpuesta es aquella que
tiene al d
no trans puesto como renglón digamos a
b2 trans puesto como otro renglón y así
sucesivamente hasta beca trans puesto
como renglón verdad ahí tenemos a
nuestra matriz a transpuesta ok entonces
qué es lo que también sabemos que el
rango de a el rango o más bien voy a
tomar de a transpuesta el rango de a
transpuesta más la nulidad más la
nulidad de transpuesta esto lo vimos en
nada ya hace algunos vídeos cité si
sumamos el rango de a transpuesta y la
nulidad de la trans pues está lo que nos
da es el número de columnas el número de
columnas y en este caso pues son en
verdad
porque esto es transpuesta y tenemos n
columnas muy bien entonces ya con esto
dicho vamos a de hecho quiero
recordarles porque esto era cierto vamos
a tomar por ejemplo cualquier matriz b
si tomamos una matriz b digamos esta
matriz b y que éste tenga no sé cómo
vectores columna b1 b2 etcétera hasta
ver no sé m
ok tenemos esta matriz b si nosotros
tomamos su forma reducida escalonada
digamos si ésta la llevamos a su forma
reducida y escalonada pues vamos a tener
algunos vectores pivote verdad algunos
vectores que son más o menos así digamos
1 0
etcétera vamos a tener otro que sea 0 1
etcétera no sé a lo mejor acá hay otro
que tenga 0001 etcétera y digamos que el
resto pues puede tener lo que sea así
cosas cosas raras no sé si sale entonces
esta es nuestra matriz reducida y
escalonada entonces qué es lo que
sabemos si estos son pivotes estos
primeros y los otros pues pueden ser
digamos que no sean pivotes que sean
libres entonces sabemos que lava una
base para el espacio columna es el
número de columnas pivote ok entonces si
yo me tomo aquí estos que son los
vectores pivote
tenemos estos los correspondientes a
quien ve van a ser una base para el
espacio columna
ok entonces ahí tenemos ahí tenemos
esa parte y sabemos además que la
nulidad también va a ser
luego que va a ser la nulidad son todos
aquellos vectores que no los vectores
columna que no fueron pivots de verdad
esto ya lo habíamos hecho en varios
vídeos digamos a lo mejor podríamos
tener varios o de hecho podríamos no
tener vectores que no sean pivote pero
bueno eso nos diría otras cosas entonces
en resumen que es lo que hemos obtenido
que si nosotros tenemos esto lo hicimos
aparte verdad si nosotros tenemos esta
matriz los vectores columnas que
resultan ser pivote eso me da una base
para el rango de la matriz y por otro
lado la nulidad está dado por el por los
vectores que no son pivots entonces ya
que tenemos esto dicho vámonos de
regreso al problema original porque
entonces si sabemos que el rango de a
transpuesta es lo mismo que el rango de
a verdad no importa para para fines del
rango no importa si es agua transpuesta
entonces qué es lo que tenemos esto lo
podemos reescribir como el rango de a
rango d
más la nulidad nulidad
de a transpuesta va a ser igual a n muy
bien pero quien es el rango de a el
rango de a pues simplemente es la
dimensión del espacio columna verdad
esto va a ser déjame ponerlo con otro
color esto será la dimensión la
dimensión del espacio columna de nuestra
matriz y por otro lado esto por
definición es la dimensión del espacio
nulo de a transpuesta muy bien y esto
debe ser igual a n
y finalmente quien era el espacio
columna pues dijimos que era nuestro
espacio vectorial así que esta es la
dimensión de nuestro espacio vectorial b
y quién es la dimensión del espacio nulo
de a transpuesta el espacio nulo de a
transpuesta dijimos que su dimensión era
igual a la dimensión del complemento
ortogonal entonces aquí vamos a tener
que esto es igual a la dimensión del
complemento ortogonal y que eso por
supuesto debe ser igual a n
entonces esto último que obtuvimos esto
último es lo que nos está demostrando
que la suma de las dimensiones de un sub
espacio y de su complemento ortogonal es
igual a la dimensión del espacio
completo es decir si tomamos b sub
espacio sub espacio de rn de rn la suma
de su dimensión con la del con la
dimensión del complemento ortogonal nos
da exactamente esta n que es la
dimensión del espacio total